hello everyone and welcome to game
number 20 of the 1960 World Chess
Championship match between Michael
Thailand the Mikhail Botvinnik and in
case you're wondering why there is a
Garry Kasparov above my head well you're
welcome to try and guess and get you
know give it your best shot in the
comment section below but it's not very
difficult I assure you
so that was four points in the lead and
well everyone is pretty much sure that
Tull will win this championship it would
be like insane if Botvinnik was able to
get get up get out of this one he would
have to start winning games and would
would white and black so it's 11 and a
half for tall and he needs 2012 and I
have to actually win this match so
either win this game or draw the next
two games at this one and the next one
and as Todd says that he thought that
Botvinnik would really give up on
actually trying to win this match but
it's this game it's game 20 that
Botvinnik
really gives it gives it his he has the
best creativity and his best attempt to
refute Todd style and also it's it's a
very nice addition to theoretical
knowledge of that time so in this game
botanique is white and he opens with c4
and alexandra complains tried to
convince tough to really try and play
this game like for real but Todd said
that he couldn't do it he he was up four
points and he couldn't take the match
seriously anymore
he said that the only thing he could
think about that this was the lat if he
manages to draw this one and the next
one then this is the last time he's
playing black against botanique this
year until the head the the return match
for the World Chess Championship
so Knight to f6 d 4e six and Knight to
c3 inviting tau for a four nimzo-indian
defense Bishop to b4 the names of Indian
and once again we have the same
variation a three bunch of captures pawn
captures and Knight to e4 so the same as
we've had in game 19 game 17 and how is
this any different well as you remember
in the previous game is about tunic
continue with Queen to c2 then we had f5
from tile the recommendation from marked
M
book but here Botvinnik actually goes
III and III is an excellent move and the
TAS says that this really is an
invitation for for a fight and if what
tunic played this sooner in the match
then probably all of the games would be
more interesting and here at all says
there is a problem now black must play
f5 if talk continues b6 for example
after Bishop to d3 attacking the knight
there should be some in defending the
knight then botanique has this option of
going Queen to g4 now there's a double
attack on the knight and an attack on
the g7 pawn and tal really didn't like
this position for black now okay I mean
you can play Knight to f6 Queen back to
g3 but White House opinion was that
white boys position is much better here
and another thing is if you remember
from my previous videos in this position
you can never capture the c3 pawn of
course because Queen to c2 and all of
this all of the retreat squares for the
knight are taken a 4 and a 4 by the
Queen and the b5 and if d5 by the c4
pawn so after e3 top plays f5 now knife
captures and c2 is definitely an option
because now after Queen to c2 Knight can
retreat to e4 and he will be protected
by the f5 pawn so here pal definitely
expected Queen to c2 defending the pawn
developing the Queen so on so on but the
bottom explai twin to h5 check and if
someone plays a move like this very
early this is move 7 if someone gives
you a checker move 7 it's probably a
terrible move it could very well be a
blunder you know you're probably playing
against someone who doesn't really know
how to play chess you know you know the
old saying don't bring your queen out
too early but when a player like me
called Botvinnik place it against you in
a World Chess Championship match
especially when he's down 4 points then
you're definitely heading into home
preparation territory so what do you do
here you don't really have a lot of
options here King to f8 that's too
adventurous even for tall
so basically g6 is a forced we have
Queen to h6 and now if you look at this
position White Queen deed did lose a
temple but look at the dark squares
around
around this Kings position black is
absent of his dark square bishop as he
traded urine on c3 so all of these dark
scores are pretty weak and the queen is
very powerful there and now if you if
you play something like Queen to g5 to
maybe try an exchange and go into the
endgame then Queen captures Knight
captures and h4 doesn't really give
black anything in 9 3 4 you can even go
h5 and this position would be very
pleasant to play for white so tall
doesn't want to go for this so after
this Queen to h6 also an idea to play
the D 6 and D 6 isn't is an interesting
idea because it kind of invites Botnick
to go for Queen to g7 which is basically
a pawn sacrifice because after after
Queen to g7 and Queen to f6 now you
offer a trade of Queens of course you
have to protect the rook now comes Queen
captures on c7 and this was Todd's idea
Knight to a6 attacking the Queen Queen
to a5 and now b6 a very very dangerous
idea
Queen a4 check kind of forcing King to
move because if you blocked in Queen
captures night but this was Todd's idea
blocking and now if Queen captures now
nice the c5 and the queen is trapped you
have to capture the night so after pawn
captures now Queen captures and c3 with
check for King to rook and the king and
after King to d1 now not capturing the
rook but actually D captures on c5 if
you capture the rook then you lose for a
very specific reason but White has the
part with the roof either way because
now now if you try to protect it would
work to be one you get roped to d8 and
you're lost there is there is not a lot
of defense against Bishop play for
double check and if you try and block
this for example Bishop d2 then you get
Bishop to c6 and it's all over
you can't defend Queen captures on d2 if
you try and block with the knight Knight
f3 simply Bishop captures that's why I
played Bishop to c6 so I very exciting
and dangerous position after this d6
move by tau inviting Botvinnik for Queen
to g7 but Botvinnik isn't interested in
this he plays f3
attack stalls night we have Knight back
to f6 and now II for a 5 brush up to g5
attacking the knight
Queen to e7 with the idea of moving the
Queen to f7 to unpin this as you can go
Queen to d7 your knight would be hanging
Queen to d3 and here rock to f8 rook to
f8 tall says this was pretty much forced
if you try and develop for example with
Knight to c6 you get he captures on f5
and after each capture somebody forward
to check then King to f1 will be very
dangerous now but when he could be
threatening rook to e1 the Queen and
King are still stuck on the e-file this
would be winning for white so after
Bishop to d3
rook to e8 rope to a favored by tau and
now comes Knight to e2 nice to e2 tall
kind of poetically says that in so many
games against the this nimzo-indian
Botnick played Knight to h3 and now when
Botvinnik should have played Knight to
h3 he plays Knight to e2 but it's not
really I mean tosses in his book that
Queen - Queen to h4 would be a better
idea and now after black finally on pins
with Queen to f7 now Bishop to h6 attack
the rock and after rook to g8 now knife
to h3 which would follow Knight to g5
infiltrating blacks position where I
mean this is a fine continuation but
actually the move botnik played knife to
e2 is the engines favorite so although
although Tao considers this to be better
both eunuchs move I mean I mean holds
the position Queen to f7 now finally
tall on pins Queen to h4 and now F
captures on e 4f captors on e4 and
Knight to g4
now tallest threatening Queen to f2 to
finally get rid of all of the pressure
and exchange some pieces we have h3
attacking the knight Queen to f2 this
comes with to check King to d2 and now
Queen captures on h4
Bishop captures on h4 and now nice to
have two attacking the rook rook H to f1
and now Knight captures on d3 so all of
the exchanges here were forced rope
captures on f8 and in between move keen
captures and now king after son b3 so
tall did manage to calm down the
situation but still all of his pieces
are undeveloped he has to do something
about this and then
everything will be okay Bishop to e6 we
have nice the g3 Knight to d7 again
developing a piece Knight to f1 and now
a six and here botnik plays Bishop to f2
which is definitely a nice move at oz
idea when he played a6 was that if
botany decides to play Knight to e3 to
play Knight to d5 to attack the c7 pawn
then b5 was Todd's idea and now if you
play this now you get pawn captures on
c4 King captures and c6 winning the
night so instead of going good the
knight the bishop to f2 by Botvinnik and
now King to g7 now Boeing b-52 anything
as you know the whole b5 idea was was
simply preparing to get rid of the night
if it came to a three now d5 is
definitely an option so Bishop has to
move and then Knight to d2 defending c4
this would be okay for white so after
night
so after this Bishop to f2 King to g7 a
preparing DF file for the rook Knight to
e2
rook to f8 now comes Bishop to e3 as the
bishop was attacked a knife to b6 rock
to be won and now Knight to f6 and it
was in this position I moved 27th at
both winning over taller draw and tall
after suffering a lot in this game as he
did run into some serious preparation
immediately agreed to a draw
yeah I mean okay you might argue that
it's a weird why would you offer a draw
here we are down four points you're
trying to maintain your title as the
World Chess Champion but you know what
when ik was like that he thinks tall
earned it you're not gonna win this game
I mean the position is equal forcing
this would maybe even lose another game
so better better to give another game a
try next game you're playing black so
maybe give your best then and even if
you lose the title you always have the
rematch so in this position both offered
to draw and tall gladly accepted it so
this is game 20 and we are one game away
from the last game of the 1960 World
Chess Championship and from ending this
series so I do hope you enjoyed this
game I do hope you enjoyed the entire
series and
if you haven't seen the entire series
there is a link in the description below
where you can check it out also I highly
recommend you check out my coverage of
the 1959 World candidates tournament the
tournament l had to win to actually
qualify to challenge botanique for the
title so those are some interesting
games so yeah once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank a Tony
Moore guitar for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
probably with the last game of the 1960
World Chess Championship thank you all
and I'll see you soon